hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay so I'm in was what someone
said follow this spider so I'm gonna
watch this little douche of us fighter
[ __ ]
Wow your son of a [ __ ] someone said
follow you so I'm gonna follow you
because you're an [ __ ] you know that
right spider huh huh you little son of a
[ __ ] think you can I you shall dab etch
pot I'll crush you ah fudge hey how
about you go screw yourself alright
screw you I'm done you go you go to hell
and you die you go to hell and you die
ah bollocks
get away you're such an a-hole alright
so Wow
your ragamuffin come on [ __ ] you spire
favorite taught me to follow the first
planner can go to hell here you're gonna
hell you gonna trying to fire [ __ ] him
whoever said ah [ __ ] you oh god damn
hate to fire spire okay anyway so the
other smarter suggestion was to find the
movable rock Oh how's much better I
thank you thank you guy who said that oh
you're the best
haha thank you oh you're so great oh man
and smart and smart and handsome or
pretty depending on your gender or
sexual identity or whatever you can be
prettier smart or whatever okay so all
right now that off [ __ ] okay it's too
dark here let me turn up I'm gonna
probably gonna have any fricken anything
for ever Siletz carefully walk across
his beam
and keep going we're fine how's normal
okay so maybe I can find yeah I can use
this wait what's this whoa what whoops I
was a mistake okay I need to take this
this board and use it to get across the
collapsed part up there easy peasy
hey whoa whoa oh oh oh oh what was that
what was that some happened some changed
okay so now that I'm over the whole
spider ordeal see if can gently ginger
aha slid right into place
thank you making my way upstairs and
everything looks hunky-dory over here
moving forward away from any stupid ass
spiders I don't even care if maybe it
led to an easter egg or something I
don't even care who's this this looks
dangerous I should probably oh hello
what that what did I just do well what
did I just do oh I just went across the
gap okay all right then
huh huh small amount of black powder
should be enough to last away these
balls you got it
isn't that a little risky as long as we
are very careful with where we place it
the bedrock should last perhaps we
should turn back
Maya was correct such as will worth the
risk
well if if if they were talking about it
why didn't they just do it then okay so
I need off all right then I just kind of
fell down I think I got bulb I don't
know what happened there
loud down at him finally they're not
giving me enough of that they keep
hurting me
it heard me it's not fair okay I need to
find some black powder with no oil
cuz haha screw me and my desire to have
oil that's just silly
where am I even going I don't even know
how I'm gonna find where I need to go Oh
another oh you're a rat okay I thought
it was a spider for a second good I got
a bad feeling about these tunnels here
all right anyway see what we got
ah you got it ah no way what what all
right so apparently this was already
hearing us was he Oh down here Bo [ __ ]
you rat picked it I can't pick up that
rock or else I totally smash you I
probably want the only direction that
led away from the black powder that I
needed that would just be my luck that
would just be my luck and what is this
gimme god it's like a labyrinth down
here I'm probably gonna get stuck on the
geometry oh what's up ah-ah-ah-ah-choo
pretty Daland oh oh oh you shut up
ah ah that's how it's gonna be eh oh god
it's true I predicted the future I
predicted the fair time stuck on the
geometry I probably was the other funds
available comes out here but just like
me I'm an idiot and I just water Dan to
death
gah [ __ ] mother you're pissed
God balls you gotta be kidding me
ha ha ha Eliza
oh where am I now
oh you got art you shut up uh aah all
right jump cutting in 3 2 1 Blair okay
we're back that's great I actually died
again
ha ha ha ha cuz I fell in the hole ok
let's go left and go back to the way see
I didn't I didn't jump down instead I
walked around and holy hell man he's
like convoluted to the maximum like I
know I know there are supposed to be
periods of up and what the hell what
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna kill
everyone you care about okay we're back
that's great let's go again and let's
not get stuck on the rocks not get stuck
on the rocks oh you son of a [ __ ] oh if
you do it again oh if you do it again I
will Jam my fist so far up your ass okay
good great fantastic we're through good
okay so we're back in here
okay shut the [ __ ] up I don't give a
[ __ ] we were supposed to go this way I
went the only direction I was not
supposed to go we were supposed to go
this'n way or is this just a circle
that's a pit where I got stuck before
wasn't it
like hell I'm going down there again you
gotta be kidding me
this bull it's a one big circle oh man
where's the friggin black powder I'm not
going down that pit again I know it's a
trap I know it's a frickin trap you're
not gonna get me again there gotta be
maybe the black powder is in this bag
maybe this black powder is this bag is
the black powder maybe who knows I'm
gonna assume that it is I'm gonna treat
this as if it is the black powder and go
on my merry way I think it's gotta be I
[ __ ] you spot not going this way screw
you and all you care about I'm just
gonna off hawk the black powder around
and not let it disturb me in any way
shape or form go over there haha there
we go okay not getting stuck being totes
mixed groats Pro I'm gonna oh when I get
out of here I'm gonna go find the
developers first I'm gonna shake their
hand for making such a good custom story
and now I'm gonna punch him in the dick
I'll punch him in the dick first then
then shake their hand yeah just a chum
yeah yeah that'll show them okay very
carefully very carefully very carefully
done I can't throw it here coz then I'll
lose it I bet this isn't even it I bet
this is not the black powder because how
the fudge what if I just tossed it up
the hole before I went over because I
got to get over that rope anyway I bet I
toss it and it falls down
I bet I toss and I miss that would be so
funny that would be just the funniest
ever you all would laugh and laugh and
laugh at me ha ha ha ha ha ha this ball
I wasn't even it I can't even see with
afar ah ha ha ha this is it this is that
who's what I wanted this is what I came
for
this is that I'm gonna kill myself
ok we're back what I did and what I shut
down a while ago is create a save here
by saving and exiting ha ha yes ha ha
can't believe I got that ok so I bet
this still isn't even the black powder
that's not it that's not it I've been
carrying around a sack of potatoes
haven't I oh damn it oh hey my life it's
not nice
ha ha hear it on a stack of potatoes and
follow the [ __ ] gunpowder
ha ha ok alright so I'll leave this sack
of potatoes here ha ha ha ha
I'm gonna punch you in the dick I'm
gonna [ __ ] sword is this it is this
it I don't know boom I don't know this
might be it this rock might be it who
knows can't see now cuz there's too much
blood in my eyeballs Oh God
pretty go there it is you know what
let's try it let's try it cuz you know
it might be it might be ha who knows who
knows these things
I don't I certainly do not to demand the
sack of potatoes very easily this would
have been much more obscure some even
was even say on it let's see delirium to
reminisce booter II applicant amorous
okay that's out like black powder let's
try it
what's wrong if it's down that hole that
I got stuck in that one time I am going
to go find everyone who worked on this
game and I'm gonna punch them so hard in
the penis and they're going to turn into
a woman that's how hard I will punch
them in the dick
alright so let's say here here I'll just
in case I don't make it on the first try
which bride won't oh god oh god I just
remember jet Jane I've totally forgotten
about Jane like I am someone else I'm
not who these I'm not like flashbacks
it'd be okay
ha I think I made it maybe I don't know
there it is
I sure hope this is black powder nope
what's that oh no no uh-uh
well isn't that weird well I guess I'll
never get back here you dick what the
wait a minute wait a minutes going on
there kind of sticks in place I've
probably not it'll throw the sack of
potatoes out yet hi hey my life
alright I'm just gonna be exploring for
a bit where the pass as this fookin look
herder oh yeah laudanum I forgot I
didn't pick that up again ah ah my life
I hate
ah
now you know before it was just me those
gonna I'm talking directly to the DES
maker of the game before it was just me
those gonna punch you in the dick now
I'm gonna get every one of my fans to go
to your house and hold you down while I
punch you in the dick
ah man where'd he go
ah Oh better carry my sack of potatoes
with me that's good oh let's just get
out of here let's just get out of here
I'll use my sack of potatoes as oh there
we go
see I knew they were gonna be useful ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha I look at this it's a
bloat [ __ ] yeah
when I reach Dartmouth I knew where to
go though I'm not sure how I knew I
found myself standing in front of
Maureen's mansion where he and hardly
had experimented on the orb I was out of
options
I had to look for answers here Charles
long Dan top tower 6 completion count of
six completion okay I'm officially all
out of time and/or patience for this map
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done everybody sign up for the
event to go punch the developer the [ __ ]
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
I'm left-handed haha please please let
me live
still - come on why are you scared